breaking news here in germany where
authorities have arrested two former
soldiers on terror charges federal
prosecutors accused the men of
attempting to form a mercenary group to
fight in yemen prosecutors say the plot
involved former soldiers and police
officers the veterans were taken into
custody following raids on their
apartments in southern germany on
wednesday morning
dw political correspondent jared reed is
following this story welcome jared what
more do we know about these people and
their motives
well phil as you say these two former
soldiers were arrested on wednesday
morning and according to investigators
they wanted to form a sort of private
army made up of up to 150
personnel with the view to fight in the
civil war in yemen and according to uh
investigators these two former soldiers
were aware that this would involve acts
of killing including of
civilians and what they say is that the
primary motivation for this was money
the view to be paid up to 40 000 euros
per soldier
per month and what they had set out to
do was to try and get third parties to
finance this particularly saudi arabia
which as we know has led the military
intervention in
yemen according to investigators at
least one of these soldiers repeatedly
tried to make contact with saudi arabia
make connections with saudi officials
but
to no avail apparently saudi arabia
never responded to to these approaches
what we also do know too is that they
have been hit with terrorism-related
charges and they're going to appear
before an investigating judge at the
german federal court of justice later on
wednesday
now this isn't the first scandal to hit
germany's armed forces does the
bundeswehr have a problem
well sections of the bundeswehr do have
a problem with extremism particularly
the elite military wing of the german
armed forces this is a branch called the
ksk and over the years germany's
military counter intelligence
office has investigated several dozen
ksk members for suspected extreme
right wing tendencies uh one section of
the ksk was actually disbanded by the
german defense minister last year she
also threatened that the whole operation
could be disbanded if it didn't uh clean
up its act
what we know more broadly in the
bundeswehr from a report last year is
that currently some 500 soldiers in the
german military are being investigated
for uh right-wing extremism all right
thank you for that dw political
correspondent jared reed